des jeux mortels pour enfants un contrat
fatale ou encore une lutte des classes
c'est le cerveau j'espère que vous allez
bien comme beaucoup d'entre vous je suis
tombé sur la série squid games ces
derniers jours et il faut qu'on en parle
rapidement alors là vous demandez
peut-être pourquoi est ce que moi je
parlerai de ce quiz game alors que ça
n'a pas forcément de lien au premier
abord avec l'actualité ou autre et bien
parce qu'en fait ce quiz games fait écho
au travail de philosophe et sociologue
parmi les plus connus de l'histoire et
s'est du coup vous allez le voir assez
passionnant à analyser alors je vous
préviens il y aura des spoils même
jeunesse pas forcément des spoils qui
vont vous empêcher de regarder la série
schéma vous l'avez pas encore vu
meilleur hakem des spoils et enfin avant
de commencer bienvenue à tous les
nouveaux qui sont sur cette chaîne
principale hugo décryptons n'est pas du
coup sur la chaîne direct du jour on est
sur l'autre chaîne sur laquelle on
développe pas mal de nouveaux contenus
ya des formats d'interviews avec mike
horn par exemple à quelques jours et les
formats de décryptage des formats de
reportages aussi qu'ils reviennent dans
les prochains jours bref beaucoup
beaucoup de choses si vous voulez
découvrir tous les contenus et ne pas
louper les suivantes évidemment pour
nous soutenir les besoins n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner directement et pourquoi
pas à activer les notifications
déjà première chose intéressante qu'on
voit dès le premier épisode les
personnes qui entrent dans le jeu
doivent signer une sorte de contrat dans
lequel il accepte les conditions du jeu
et ça déjà c'est intéressant car le fait
qu'il signe un contrat ça légitime
ensuite ces maîtres du jeu à exercer une
certaine violence pendant les épreuves
sur les candidats en lui même le contrat
n'est pas valide puisqu'il ne mentionne
pas du tout que les joueurs risquent
leur vie en participant à ce jeu mais
comme ils ont signé et bien ça leur met
une certaine forme de pression
psychologique en gros et bien les
candidats acceptent de rentrer dans le
jeu et très concrètement accepter les
règles ça veut dire qu'ils vont devoir
accepter d'obéir et subir l'autorité des
hommes en rouge alors cette organisation
que je viens d'évoquer avec ce contrat
elle fait écho d'une certaine façon aux
travaux de l'un des sociologues les plus
connus de l'histoire il s'agit en fait
de max weber qui a beaucoup parlé de ce
qu'il appelle la violence légitime de
l'état en gros il explique que l'état
donc l'état français par exemple est
autorisée à utiliser la violence contre
la population car les citoyens acceptent
d'une certaine façon
l'organisation de la société dans
laquelle la police est reconnu comme
l'autorité principale c'est à dire la
seule qui est selon cette structure
légitime à utiliser la violence et donc
il vient il ya un parallèle ici à faire
puisque dans ce tweet games le jeu est
comme une mini société dans laquelle
l'autorité ce sont donc les hommes en
rouge et s'ils avouent être membre de
cette mini société eh bien vous acceptez
d'une certaine façon de vous soumettre à
cette autorité alors après évidemment
cette violence légitime elle peut être
contestée elle peut être remise en cause
ça aura l'occasion d'en reparler un peu
plus tard mais au passage et bien il
faut aussi noter que ces notions là font
ainsi écho aux travaux cette fois ci
d'un philosophe thomas sops le
philosophe anglais thomas soft avec le
léviathan il lui développe notamment
même si mais c'est quand même beaucoup
plus complexe que ça mais l'idée que eh
bien l'état est comme un monstre qui
d'une certaine façon soumet les
habitants parce qu'il est le plus fort
alors vous l'avez sûrement remarqué mais
vous avez vu la série le maître du jeu
répète souvent aux joueurs que les
joueurs sont égaux et effectivement et
bien tout porte à croire qu'ils sont
égaux face aux épreuves ils ont presque
tous le même âge ils portent le même
uniforme et tout le monde commence les
épreuves avec le même niveau
d'information en théorie mais le truc
c'est que en réalité lorsque les jeux
commencent eh bien ils ne sont plus du
tout ego certaines personnes sont
avantagés car elles ont déjà joué à ces
jeux d'autres triche en trompant les
plus faibles certains ont des
connaissances que les autres n'ont pas
grâce à leur métier par exemple avec par
exemple l'épisode des vitres en verre
mais vous l'avez vu bref la soi-disant
égalité entre les joueurs on réalise au
fur et à mesure n'existe pas alors quel
est le rapport avec notre société et
bien nous aussi depuis qu'on est jeune
et bien on nous le répète notamment à
l'école on est tous égaux c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'égalité des chances c'est en
gros se dire que tout citoyen peut
importe d'où il vient commence dans la
vie avec les mêmes chances que les
autres or spoiler et bien cette égalité
des chances elle n'existe pas par
exemple le sociologue pierre bourdieu
explique qu'on n'est pas égaux car on a
tous un capital culturel un capital
économique social et symbolique
différence et ce qu'il appelle lui les
quatre capitaux et concrètement ça veut
dire que c'est bien si on est dans une
famille qui a les moyens d'aller au
cinéma au théâtre d'avoir une
bibliothèque riche chez soi de voyager
etc etc eh bien on a plus de chance de
faire des grandes études et donc d'avoir
un métier ensuite il va nous permettre
de gagner beaucoup d'argent là où est
bien à l inverse chez mon se retrouve
dans une famille assez pauvre qui n'a
pas eu cette éducation de base etc eh
bien on part avec un désavantage
certaine façon dans cette société du
coup selon le sociologue pierre bourdieu
et bien l'égalité entre les citoyens
n'est pas possible tout comme l'égalité
donc entre les joueurs dans street games
qui n'existe pas bref bourdieu n'a pas
vu scrute games et s'il était encore
vivant il dirait sûrement que c'est une
série qui illustrent que l'égalité des
chances n'existe pas et que la
méritocratie du coup n'existe pas non
plus dans ce jeu
alors un autre point qui me semble assez
intéressant à souligner ici c'est que
tous les joueurs sont des personnes en
fait qu'ils vivent plus ou moins en
marge de la société ils sont endettés et
ils ne sont pas très bien intégré au
sein de la société lorsqu'ils rejoignent
le jeu alors là dessus ça c'est
intéressant de se pencher sur les
travaux du sociologue howard becker qui
en fait conceptualisé ce que l'on
appelle des déviants pour la société
c'est à dire en fait des personnes qui
ne rentrent pas dans les normes de la
société et qui du coup sont moins
intégrés à cette société et donc sont
presque invisibles aux yeux des autres
tellement sont en marge de celle-ci et
du coup si on applique cette théorie ce
concept de déviance et de déviants a
swingué mais bien le fait que les
organisateurs choisissent des personnes
endettées donc des personnes qui d'une
certaine façon en fait ne respectent pas
les normes et les règles de la société
eh bien ça leur permet d'avoir des
personnes dont la disparition ne sera
quasiment pas remarqué d'ailleurs je
pense même qu'on peut aller encore plus
loin puisque quand les personnages
rentrer chez eux dans l'épisode 2 et
donc qui quitte le jeu et qui quitte ce
quils games et bien ils sont tellement
en marge de la société et leur vie en
fait est tellement insurmontable en
raison de cette déviance en raison de
cet endettement important et du fait
qu'ils sont exclus de la société qui
préfèrent en fait au final retourner
dans ce quick game retourner dans le jeu
quitte à mourir et subir une violence
inouïe ça montre donc à quel point pour
ces personnes jugés déviants par howard
baker et bien la vie en société est
quasiment insurmontable c'est bien donc
y retourne mon jeu et au passage c'est
assez intéressant de noter que l'épisode
2 donc le seul épisode où les personnes
sont à l'extérieur du jeu bien cet
épisode a été nommé en faire
[Musique]
mais la série critique également
l'exclusion sociale c'est à dire donc
lorsqu'une personne et rechutes et de la
société pour différentes raisons comme
sa situation économique son origine son
handicap ou même son genre par exemple
lorsque les joueurs doivent faire des
équipes sur l'épreuve de la corde par
exemple eh bien ils vont avoir tendance
à rejeter les personnes les plus faibles
donc en l'occurrence notamment des
personnes âgées ou encore des femmes qui
sont jugés moins fortes que les hommes
pour ce jeu est d'ailleurs à ce propos
vous avez peut-être vu ce même du seul
joueur âgé qui se retrouve assis dans un
coin lorsqu'il faut choisir les binômes
bref le message de cette séquence c'est
clairement de montrer que dans une
société même petit et bien les personnes
les plus faibles peuvent être mises de
côté au passage autre indice qui nous
montre que la série dénoncent
l'exclusion lorsqu'on apprend au cours
d'un épisode qu'un des joueurs est
handicapé et qu'il lui manque deux
doigts et bien à ce moment là une autre
personne lui conseille de cacher sa main
pour éviter justement de dévoiler son
handicap aux autres et donc de se mettre
en danger en se montrant faible
[Musique]
dans la série un certain nombre de
personnages sont imaginés comme étant
des symboles des classes précaire des
classes les plus pauvres on en a qui
symbolise la classe ouvrière qui
galèrent d'autres qui représente les
travailleurs migrants qui ont du mal à
être intégrés à la société sud coréenne
et enfin et bien on en a encore d'autres
qui représente des réfugiés et plus
particulièrement ceux qui fuient la
corée du nord al'inverse les maîtres du
jeu sont représentés comme des personnes
qui sont très riches ils ont en fait
tellement d'argent qu'il s'amuse à
parier comme ça sur les joueurs et à les
voir se battre pour survivre un peu
comme on avait à l'époque les
gladiateurs de l' empire romain et
d'ailleurs on se rend bien compte que
ils ne sont que des pions pour les
organisateurs puisque lorsqu'il rentre
dans le jeu et bien leur nom et leurs
prénoms sont remplacés par des numéros
autrement dit donc bien les participants
aux jeux sont complètement déshumanisée
et ils n'ont plus leur propre identité
il a encore sa fille d'une certaine
façon écho aux travaux de sociologues ou
encore de philosophie politique et
notamment les travaux de cas marx donc
grandes figures de la gauche grande
figure à la fois du communisme et du
socialisme et qui lui a théorisé ça
autour de son concept de la lutte des
classes
en gros il explique que dans la société
d'un côté il ya les bourgeois et de
l'autre côté il ya les prolétaires en
groupe faire très simple les plus
pauvres et les bourgeois et bien domine
dans ce mode de société capitalistique
les prolétaires karl marx veut même plus
loin en expliquant que les riches
détiennent le capital donc l'argent et
les précaires et bien ils n'ont pas cet
argent là mais par contre ils ont leur
force de travail qui vont donc utiliser
en allant par exemple l usine et dans la
série bien le capital est clairement
représenté par la tirelire et la force
de travail et de son côté est bien
imagée par la force des joueurs dans les
épreuves en gros selon certains la série
est finalement une métaphore de la
société dans laquelle les riches
s'enrichissent
et s'amuse grâce aux plus pauvres en
pariant notamment sur eux ou alors les
utilisant comme force de travail et les
pauvres de leur côté et c'est tout
simplement de sortir la tête de l'eau
[Musique]
d'ailleurs car mark va encore plus loin
dans sa réflexion puisque lui explique
qu'un jour peut-être et bien les
prolétaires
renverseront l'ordre des classes
sociales c'est à dire qu'en gros et bien
ils vont faire la révolution contre les
bourgeois c'est ce qu'il appelle lui le
grand soir et là en l'occurrence on
pourrait donc simon fait le parallèle
avec la série totalement imaginer comme
ce qui s'est passé dans ringer games et
bien que à les joueurs de squid games se
révolte dans une éventuelle saison 2
contre les riches organisateurs du jeu
bref vous l'aurez compris ce quiz games
une série qui est logiquement
divertissante d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas à
me dire dans les commentaires ce que
vous en avez pensé l'au-delà ça je
trouve ça assez intéressant de faire des
parallèles avec des grands concepts de
sociologues ou de philosophes connu
c'est assez intéressant de voir que et
bien que ce soit volontaire ou non que
ce soit voulu ou non par les
réalisateurs et bien même des parallèles
intéressantes peuvent être faits avec
ces travaux là et donc voilà ça me
semblait assez intéressant de le faire
dans cette vidéo aujourd'hui jamais ça
vous a plu bien n'hésitez pas à me le
dire directement les commentaires
toujours preneurs de vos retours la
scène vidéo un peu différente de ce
qu'on a l'habitude de faire je vais
d'ailleurs vous êtes nouveau sur la
chaîne et bien n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner pour ne pas louper les vidéos
suivantes et puis voilà on se dit du
coup à très vite sur cette chaîne pour
plus de décryptage plus de reportages
plus interview n'hésitez pas à découvrir
nos autres contenus chez mais ce n'est
pas encore le cas et on se dit du coup a
très vite
[Musique]